earlier this hour we told you about the
political fight in congress over the one
trillion dollar infrastructure bill now
advocates worry about the fate of new
auto safety rules that are tucked inside
that measure including one for vehicle
seats it was prompted by a cbs news
investigation that revealed potential
seat back dangers linked to a government
safety standard that may be outdated
chris van cleave has been investigating
the story since 2015. he joins us now
from the capitol chris that's a long
time good morning to you
well good morning gail it's been a long
six years and that's why we've been
following this so closely of course that
infrastructure bill will begin being
considered by the house later today and
tucked inside of it along with the tens
of billions of dollars for things like
roads and bridges airports and waterways
are a host of auto safety initiatives
including one inspired by our
six-year-long cbs news investigation
it aims to change a regulation that
safety advocates say is dangerously
outdated and causing some crashes to
turn deadly
crash tests like this one are an open
secret among car makers
our cbs news investigation found it's
been known for decades when hit from
behind the front seats in all types of
passenger vehicles can collapse
launching occupants into the back seat
the injuries can be catastrophic
something the fraser family lives every
day how has life changed in every way in
every way it's like bc and a.d like
there's a definitiveness of we talk
about our life before and after because
there
there's no comparison
jaden faith was a 12 year old full of
motion a competitive dancer and an
eight-time state champion gymnast
but on thanksgiving 2016 everything
changed the family was driving home from
serving meals to the homeless when their
car was rear-ended when it happened it
was like a bomb went off something's
wrong very wrong because she was just
slumped and convulsing she died on the
side of the road the paramedics put her
into an ambulance they said with no
light in her eyes she was gone
but somehow jfe as her parents call her
survived despite a 360 degree skull
fracture are you ready and a
life-changing traumatic brain injury
leaving her unable to walk or speak
what do you miss is there something you
miss most
probably hearing her
um her voice i would imagine it would be
yeah that's my that's my number one yeah
but you've got lots you know
um
i miss seeing her dance
the fraziers are not alone we've
identified dozens of families that know
their pain all too well while regulators
acknowledge these types of crashes are
under reported safety advocates estimate
at least 50 people a year mostly
children in the back seat die from them
but the seats all meet or exceed federal
safety standards set by a regulation
dating back to the 1960s
one we proved even a banquet chair can
pass 200. i really do feel that the time
is now new york congresswoman kathleen
rice learned of the issue from our
investigation and led the effort in the
house to fix the problem i think that
credit should be given to cbs for for
you
to identify this issue inside the
infrastructure bill is language
requiring the national highway traffic
safety administration to draft a new
updated strength standard for vehicle
seats within two years but requires the
approval of the secretary of
transportation before it can be
implemented this is a fix that's going
to happen the car manufacturers know it
and we're going to get it done but
progressive democrats are now
threatening to join house republicans
and vote down the infrastructure bill
unless the president's 3.5 trillion
dollar budget act passes first they
argue infrastructure alone fails to
address the needs of the nation the
political wrangling has this potentially
life-saving reform hanging in the
balance
what do you say to the washington
politicians the longer that you guys
wait you're just adding to the list of
people just like us letting children and
adults die in these rear end car wrecks
and it's unnecessary
safety advocates would have liked to
seen stronger language that just
mandated changing the regulation instead
of also having the secretary of
transportation have to approve it the
frasiers say any movement to action now
is better than waiting for a perfect
plan it has been nearly exactly six
years since our first piece on this ran
in october of 2015.
in that time a conservative estimate is
at least 300 people have died in these
crashes most likely children
tony
chris it's an incredible report and it
seems like a simple fix would save a lot
of lives and also a lot of heartache for
families like the one you just
showed us thank you very much